voici la dame à la casse
c'est la plus
si on d'un visa
main sculpté il y à 25
dans un petit morceau d'ivoire de
quelques centimètres et elle est
considérée comme l'une des premières
oeuvres d'art de l'humanité c'est
comment vous êtes curieux vous demandez
qui a pu faire cela pour qui pourquoi et
est une simple décoration
un bijou un cadeau ou une offrande
votive derrière une oeuvre d'art il y à
l'aspect esthétique mais il ya aussi
toute l'histoire et le contexte associé
de l'oeuvre une oeuvre d'art peut
s'inscrire dans la culture actuelle
ou alors en opposition à sa culture par
exemple cette oeuvre est vraiment
atypique car les futurs venus prier
préhistorique ne rompt pas ses traits
marqués du visage et du cou à travers
ces étapes ce sont les hommes de
l'époque qui nous parle mais
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas
tracer de manière précise l'histoire de
cette oeuvre à part avoir recours à
notre imagination
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
peut-on faire mieux aujourd'hui que
restera-t-il de ce que nous créons dans
5000 10000 ans avons nous un moyen de
tracer l'histoire d'une oeuvre d'art et
surtout sur quel support utilisé quel
langage utilisé pour tracer une oeuvre
d'art donc j'aimerais avec vous inventez
une solution qui regroupe deux de mes
activités au quotidien donc la première
je pratique la sculpture la sculpture
sur pierre
je pense que la pierre est un bon médium
pour perdurer et donc pour l'instant je
ris j'essaye de reproduire la dame à la
capuche en plus primitif comme vous
pouvez le constater pour le support nous
pouvons grave et l'histoire dans cette
pierre maintenant pour le langage nous
pouvons nous tourner vers les
mathématiques
plus précisément la cryptographie la
cryptographie va nous permettre
d'enregistrer de manière unique une
oeuvre d'art et d'authentifier ce que
nous enregistrons la cryptographie n'est
pas nouvelle c'est un art ancien utilisé
dès l'antiquité pour chiffrer des
messages un art devenu science à part
entière avec l'avènement de
l'informatique
les années 70 donc nous avons deux
outils la pierre pour graver notre
histoire la cryptographie comme langage
universel
mais maintenant avons nous un moyen de
propager cette information et c'est là
que je propose d'utiliser la blocs
chaîne donc la bloque chaîne qu'est ce
que c'est quels sont les propriétés qui
vous ans qui vont nous intéresser
et en quoi va-t-elle nous permettre de
propager notre avoir informations la
blocs chaîne c'est avant tout un
agencement ingénieux de technologies
existantes
ça va regrouper la technologie internet
les réseaux pair-à-pair les bases de
données distribués et tout ceci va
permettre un horodatage temporelle des
ayvelles des événements que l'on veut
enregistrer et donc cet agencement
ingénieux en informatique c'est ce qu'on
appelle un protocole donc là blocs
chaîne c'est avant tout un protocole et
un protocole qu'est ce que c'est c'est
un ensemble de règles pour bien
communiquer les protocoles que vous
utilisez tous les jours c'est par
exemple à un protocole de messagerie
lorsque vous envoyez un message vous
respecter un ensemble de règles qui vous
permettent d'échanger des messages
un protocole tedx avec un rond rouge une
salle lumière tamisée un temps limité un
ensemble de règles pour bien communiquer
et donc pour qualifier ce protocole n'a
blocs scène c'est un protocole de
transfert
c'est à dire que respecter le protocole
va nous assurer la non duplication de la
donner et du coup de la conservation de
sa valeur si je l'information sera comme
un jeton ce jeton je peux le posséder ou
je peux le transférer et quand je le
transfert le protocole m'assure que vous
avez ce jetons mais surtout que je ne
l'est plus et donc pour la haute chaîne
protocole de transfert
la dernière partie pour la propagation
ça va être pair à pair l'information ne
sera pas porté par une seule entité mais
distribué dans un réseau c'est le réseau
qui va posséder
l'information ce réseau sera distribuée
décentralisée et c'est exactement ce que
nous voulons pour l'histoire de notre
oeuvre nous ne voulons pas que ce soit
une seule entité qui serait vouée à
disparaître sur des milliers d'années
ici nous allons utiliser des réseaux
publics qui sont composées de dizaines
de milliers de noeux et cela va nous
assurer une universalité et être plus
résilient à l'oubli pour l'histoire que
nous voulons laisser de notre oeuvre
cette information j'ai dit que c'était
un jeton mais ça peut être représenter
une monnaie une crypto monnaie mais
cette information peut être aussi un
droit un droit d'accès un droit de vote
et dans notre cas ce sera un droit de
propriété d'une oeuvre
donc nous avons vu les éléments de base
de la blocs chaîne maintenant
accrochez-vous nous allons enregistrer
notre entière et son histoire pour des
milliers d'années
la première chose que l'on fait c'est
grâce à la cryptographie on va générer
une adresse et cette adresse on va
l'associer à du code
ça va être comme un registre dédié pour
notre oeuvre d'art cette adresse et son
code nous déployons sur la blogo chaîne
et ça devient ce qu'on va appeler un
agent autonome vous verrez peut-être
dans la littérature sur le sujet qu'on
appelle sa smart contracte mais je
préfère l'appeler agents autonomes cet
agent autonome va représenter notre
oeuvre d'art et donc qu'il va être au
début comme un simple registre c'est à
dire qu'on va voir le créateur de cette
oeuvre
la description puis va venir tous les
prochains propriétaires de l'oeuvre qui
vont pouvoir être enregistrées dans ce
registre et l'intéressant c'est qu'un
propriétaire de l'oeuvre d'art peut à
tout moment
montrer la preuve cryptographique de sa
possession de cette oeuvre d'art donc on
a vu que ça peut nous servir comme un
simple registre mais comment lier les
deux comment lier cet agent autonome et
l'oeuvre en question
pour cela je propose qu au moment de la
signature de l'oeuvre d'art
l'artiste va à côté sa signature
habituelle rentrée cette adresse et
sainte adresse sera comme le fil
d'ariane à suivre
pour trouver toute l'histoire de
l'oeuvre d'art donc nous avons vu que
nous pouvons faire des registres simple
mais l'intérêt c'est que nous allons
pouvoir ajouter des règles des nouvelles
règles par exemple imaginons que vous
êtes le créateur et vous voulez qu à
chaque qu'une nouvelle vente de votre
oeuvre vous recevez une part
des bénéfices des nouvelles ventes c'est
quelque chose que pour vous écoute codée
dans votre logique et la déployer et si
vous êtes un artiste voulait instaurer
une sorte de démocratie vous pouvez
écrire des règles comme quoi toute
personne qui possède l'oeuvre peut voter
pour le pan pourcentage qui est attribué
à aux créateurs ni sial et donc on voit
que ici on est la signature n'est plus
une fin en soi mais peut être le début
d'une nouvelle histoire une histoire qui
va être encodé de manière décentralisée
dans cet agent autonome et ceci dans un
registre public accessible à tous ainsi
marc contracte les gens autonomes ne
contraint pas il est là il propose une
si vous voulez interagir avec lui vous
vous interagissez si vous ne voulez pas
vous n'interagissent pas avec lui ici la
proposition de valeur c'est de pouvoir
créer une histoire décentralisée grâce à
un langage qu'est la cryptographie et
ceci dans un registre dynamique est
accessible à tous et c'est en soi même
une craint une nouvelle création
artistique qui commence donc nous avons
vu dans cette présentation que la
technologie peut changer notre façon
d'organiser nos échanges et je pense que
c'est un moyen pour nous de réfléchir
sur les déséquilibres qui peuvent être
présents aujourd'hui dans l'accumulation
toujours de bien la richesse des gens ce
n'est pas forcément dans l'accumulation
excessive et déséquilibrée de bien mais
nous sommes vraiment riche de ce que
nous pouvons échanger et de ce que nous
pouvons créer le pont pour moi le
lapdock 100 donc cesser des nouveaux
outils pour pour faire cette
collaboration et je suis j'ai parlé
d'oeuvres d'art mais je pense le mot
important c'est le mot oeuvre l'oeuvre
c'est votre travail de demain c'est ce
que vous allez faire pour moi je suis
entrepreneur depuis quelques semaines et
c'est un changement du sens du travail
c'est le changement du pass passé de
l'entrepreneur du salariat à
l'entrepreneuriat passer du labeur à l'
ouvrage la blocs chaîne est là pour
innover et tracer une histoire de
manière innovante pour les oeuvres d'art
à vous aussi d'innover et tracer votre
histoire pour pour votre futur métier
je vous souhaite de trouver le sens qui
vous conduira vers votre métier vos
études ne sont pas une accumulation de
compétences mais une invitation à
trouver votre pierre à apporter à
l'édifice et vos oeuvres à créer dans
vos métiers respectifs ne devenait pas
des techniciens mais des ouvriers ou
plutôt des ouvriers et je terminerai par
une citation que j'ai fait mienne qui va
dans ce sens du passage de la technique
à l' ouvrage apprend les règles comme un
professionnel afin de pouvoir les briser
comme un artiste
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]